بدأوا يطالبون بشيء أكثر
أنهم طالبوا بالاستقالات لكنهم
يطالبون بشكل أساسي في مكان معين
بنوع مختلف من الحكومة بنمط مختلف
من الحكم بطريقة يمكننا من خلالها
البدء في بناء شكل حقيقي من
المواطنة يمكن أن
يقود البلاد  بلد خارج من
الأزمة المالية والفقر ومنحنا
فرصة للعيش بكرامة ، هذا
حقًا ما يدور حوله ،
لذا فإن الكرامة مهمة جدًا بالنسبة لنا ،
فالإنصاف مهم جدًا ، والرغبة
في دولة غير فاسدة
مهمة للغاية ولكنها واحدة من الصدارة  القضايا
الخاصة ببلدك هي الطائفية
وكان هذا نوعًا من الواقع الفعلي
في عالم ما بعد الحرب الأهلية ، كيف
يبدو المستقبل إذا كان لا بد من مشاركة هذه المكاتب الرئيسية
بينك وبين الأديان المختلفة
والمسلمين السنة والمسلمين الشيعة  النظرة الدرزية
، أعني إذا سمعت الأغاني
هناك ما يقولونه في الواقع هو
أننا أخيرًا تحررنا من هذه
الانقسامات ، فأنا لست موهومًا.
تخيل أن الطائفية لن
تختفي بين عشية وضحاها ولكن ما
ألاحظه هو أنه على مدى السنوات القليلة الماضية
كان هناك حركة واحدة تلو الأخرى
تتخذ مواقف متزايدة
ضد الطائفية ، يشعر الناس بشكل متزايد
بأن الطريقة التي يتم
تصنيفهم بها إلى طوائف  والجماعات الدينية
تقوض بشكل أساسي
إمكانية بناء أمة